good morning
good morning members good morning and
welcome to members of the public
uh i do apologize for the late start
we've had um
a difficulty with one of our public
speakers trying to join we're trying to
sort this out
while we're doing the formalities
because she
wants to take part in the first
application so we're attempting to solve
that problem
welcome to this meeting of the planning
committee of baby district council the
24th of march 2021.
my first of all remind you of some of
the domestic arrangements
please ensure that the microphones and
cameras are turned off when not in use
that you do not interrupt other speakers
that if you wish to speak
point of order declare and interest or
request in the german
please use the hands up function on the
taskbar
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative
communication lines open i.e other teams
chats
or the emojos oh sorry use the emojos
and and that
you are and that if you are contacted by
a third party during an application you
should bring this to the legal advisor's
attention and that
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
if members do lose connection to the
meeting
they must contact the member support
officer mandy smith as soon as possible
you all have that telephone number we
will be using
modern.gov to conduct all electronic
votes during the meeting
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the hold of the meeting will be recorded
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council
to have consented to being recorded by
entering this meeting as a speaker you
are also consenting to being recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those same recordings for webcast and
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
i'd like to introduce you to the team
today mark russell area planning manager
jamie weinard case officer jeffrey
martin edwards
case officer andy press cannon lawyer
officer i'd now like to move to the
agenda
item number one is apologies for absence
do we have any i think we're all present
thank you chair we don't have any
apologies for this morning's meeting
good item number two
to do decorations of interest are there
any to declare members
counselor uh owen yes yes thank you mr
chairman
um i would like to to close a lot local
non
can you
[Music]
i would like to close a lot local
nonproluna interest
in the acton item as uh as i'm known to
the applicant however there is no
influence from the relationship i'll
remain
the debate and take part in the vote
thank you
[Music]
thank you chair um again i have known
the um
the applicants um for about 15 years
mainly through um civic things and
the town twinning but they're not um
sort of um
known to me as a particular friend but i
do know them so i do declare
non-pecuniary interest thank you chair
thank you i asked our legal
officer to comment indeed good morning
chairman ladies and gentlemen i'm just
to confirm both
both counsellors took my advice before
the start in the meeting and i can
confirm that
in my opinion those uh interests have
been declared properly as
local non-procurement then in neither
case are there anything close to a
pecuniary interest and it does not
appear to me
that they there's any uh inference to be
drawn of bias or predetermination
or or any interest leading to such thank
you
so no other interests being declared
we'll move on to item number three to
confirm the minutes of the meeting held
on the 10th of march
it all been sent electronic copy of
these there's 13 pages quite a lot to go
through
is there any comments
or points of accuracy please
no oh sorry counselor airs your hand is
up
is that an old hand
no sorry chair it's just to say i have
read them and i will propose that we
accept them thank you oh you're
proposing them thank you do i have a
second uh
i'll second that yeah uh thank you
cancer
jameson um right there's no other
comments
so i'll take that proposal and sector
we need to go to the electronic vote is
that correct um
mandy sadly chair you've got me today
not mandy for the electronic vote
you're making up your mind you told me
it was mandy mandy's
in the live stream this morning chair
and after i'll be doing all the
electronic votes
so um with your permission chair i will
start the electronic vote
so if members could please go to the
modern.gov
app and go to the plus sign in the top
right hand corner of today's agenda and
click on the subsection for voting slash
attendance
the vote will appear in a light blue
color under pl2
11 and it will be
apologies i'm having to just get to the
right point
and it will appear in a light blue color
when the vote is live
the vote should now be live chair
oh yes there it is
right um have we all voted
yep that's every one chair and that's a
unanimous vote in favor of
approving the minutes thank you and now
we close it and go back to
the symbol don't we close yes yeah
that's the bit to remember thank you
very much for that
uh right then we'll move on to receive
notifications of petitions
in accordance with the council's
petition scheme
i think you have one to explain to us uh
robert
thank you chair so we have one petition
to report to the meeting this morning
regarding the first application on the
agenda of dc 2005
3 i'll read out the statements regarding
that point and the number of total valid
signatures
so we the under sign petitioned the
council to decline the planning
application
dc 20 five
three six one land south east of barrow
hill acton
co ten zero a s
there is extensive and recent local
objection to this application
the extent of which is not necessarily
apparent from the number objection
showing on the planning site
this has been signed in total by 15
70 1570 people and was validated this
morning
at a final total of 1211 after 359
signatures were rejected under the
petitions scheme rules
so just confirm the total of such
number of signatures is 1211. this won't
show on the website as of yet as
i hope members can appreciate this was
validated only this morning
and we haven't had time to update the
website for that fact yet so if there's
any points on that chair
um i'll leave it there uh can i asked
the 359 i think it was
object uh rejected ones
the reasons or without going into too
much detail but
i think the main reason chair to um and
we're communicating this to the
lead petitioner as well is the fact that
they were not in the district
so under the labour petition rules the
um
if i just get the right part in front of
me here
so that i can be clear to members about
what we are talking about so the
petition scheme
requires
that any person who lives works or
studies
can sign the petition area but the
petition
submitted must include the following
detail the name address or place of work
or study
of any person supporting the petition
and support as a petitioner can be
anyone who lives works or studies in the
area of the district council
so anywhere outside of babel where they
have given an address
and not indicated that they live work or
study in baby
have to be discounted under the scheme
thank you
that's very clear thank you uh
right so that's the only petition you've
received
yes yeah thank you so we'll move on to
item number five which is site
inspections
officers are there any site inspection
requests
i'll take that as no mark
no thank you uh members are there any
site
inspection requests
and i see no hands going up so there's
none there thank you
so we'll move on to item number six
which is scheduled planning applications
and 6a is land at south east of barrow
hill
acton i now invite case officer jamie
martin edwards to introduce the
application to the committee
good morning jamie looking very smart
over to you
thank you very much and good morning
members um i
have got the presentation on screen so
if we can just check that everyone can
see that
yes yes sorry yes and you can all hear
me loud and clear yeah
yep excellent stuff but if i just start
the
presentation
brilliant stuff thank you very much so
i'll be presenting this morning the
application for land south
uh east of barrow hill in acton
in by way of an introduction this is an
outline consent for up to a hundred
dwellings
this includes playstation play space
land for a scout hut and a nature area
those three will be
captured by section 106 and the
application
does consider access as well that means
that appearance
scale landscaping and layout are all
matters
that are reserved also to make members
aware that there is an extent
outline permission on this site back
from 2017
currently the outline permission has
until the first of may 2021 for the
reserve matters to be submitted
those reserve matters could be submitted
on the 1st of may and we would need to
determine those
so briefly showing the sites in
situ i'll go into a lot wider detail in
a second
but just to show that we have site
outlined here
and this is where the proposed access
will go again i'll be going in a lot
more finer detail in a second regarding
that
so just going out wider just to show
where adam sits and resides
within the uh functional cluster we have
sudbury
here long melford over to the west
great welding field to the east little
welding field here with actin in the
middle
obviously the chilton woods
development that's going in the north
here i've also just outlined
where the site sits in the red line
just going in a little bit closer and
chair just to check that my slides are
running in time i do know sometimes they
they delayed
we'll capture that values at the moment
brilliant stuff okay so this site is
outlined in red here
uh we do have the access as well that
will come here i haven't shown that on
this slide
i've also just noted here the tamage
road site in acton
where development was granted after the
2017 permission was granted outline
permission here
but as subsequently works have been
commenced on this site
already i'm also just highlighted that
we've got the primary school
kind of in the center of acton set
behind the houses
on high street we've also got the
village hall just up here
the church public house is just located
here
and a convenience shop with bus stops
along high street here
just zoom in a little bit further and
again just to get our
directions sorted we've got barrow hill
which runs
in the north easterly direction behind
the site
we have the high street that runs along
here
and that turns into waldingfield street
down on
the southeast we have the convenience
stores just inside here you can just
look there also points to uh remember is
we've got the community woodland
just north of the site which separates
from barrow hill
and we have the allotment section here
we also have public footpath 9 which
runs on the east side of the allotments
down the eastern side of the site inside
the boundary line
and then it comes into this cluster of
trees here and breaks out
out into high streets here
you'll note that there is also some
other walkways that you can see on the
map
these aren't necessarily a public right
of way but are used locally
and indeed when i did my site visit i
walked around this whole site
keeping to those paths
so again just another outline um just to
show a little bit more detail
in terms of a block plan and again you
can see the public right-of-way
for path nine there and you also notice
now that we've got the access showing as
well in red
that joins onto high street and that is
within the cartilage of a single
dwelling here which will need to be
demolished
in terms of constraints map we have the
built up
settlement boundary area shown in kind
of a maroon color
you'll notice it attaches onto the
western boundary of the site
the site is separated from the
settlement boundary to the north by that
community
woodland and to the south it's only
separated by the settlement boundary by
the rear gardens of dwellings that
face high street also very important
points here for consideration members
is that we have marigold and if i just
zoom in a little bit i might be able to
see that a little bit better
so we've got marigold there is a grade
two listed building directly opposite
the access
and hopefully i'm pronouncing this one
right is speed dives i understand
another grade two listed building we
have a single
grade ii listed building that's been
subdivided into
two dwellings known as lilac cottage and
sunflower cottage here
because i have pool house grade 2 listed
building located here
if i just zoom back out again i've got a
cluster of greater listed buildings over
to the west
and another one here and we also have
the grade one
vistage church in the north west
area so point out
this is where our heritage uh team have
identified that harm would take place
with having the access directly opposite
the listed building currents our
heritage team are only seeing this as
less than substantial harm
we have inquired with them in terms of
what the impact of having this field
developed into housing would have at
this stage that they have no concerns
and more detail would come forward as
part of the reserve matters
however together we have acknowledged
that we are looking at a less than
substantial harm
in terms of the listed buildings by
developing this site
of which we obviously give great weight
as per the mppf requirements in the
decision making
and it's also set out in the report
so just to go into the details of the
access
so we can see here this is the existing
dwelling
that will be demolished to allow for the
access to come into place
high street that runs along here
currently has a 30 mile an hour speed
limit in place
if i just zoom in a little bit the blue
dotted line
you should be able to see denotes the
visibility splays
and we can see that we've got 62.5
meters
either way on the visibility displays
and you'll also notice some of the
objections that we've received say that
this visibility space crosses
third-party land
you can see here quite clearly that it
goes right up to but does not cross
third-party land it always stays in
highways ownership so there's no
concerns that the
highway would be or the visibility space
would be impeded in this instance
and i think also a point to note in
terms of some of the objections that
we've received
we see up here that the footpath
alongside the access into the site has
been denoted as being two meters wide
we expect that would take place there is
no additional annotation for the
footpath width in this area
and it would be logic to to
assume that the two meters means it's
for the whole footpath it doesn't
i've measured this on a scaled on the
scale drawing
this is less than two meters here as set
out in the
report there will be a widening of the
footpath here which i'll come on to in a
little while
there has been a speed survey that's
taken place
on the high street and this has seen a
sort of average speed of around about 38
miles per hour
this would mean that we wouldn't have
we'd have enlarged visibility displays
to the normal
uh that we would expect in terms of a 30
mile an hour zone
and the 62 meters doesn't quite
match what we would expect in that
instance but we also have a suite of
improvements to the road in terms of
speed reductions and that has satisfied
our highways colleagues and these will
be captured as part of a section 278
agreement
i understand that conversations and
discussions had been ongoing with the
highways department as part of the
extant permission already
and i think what is also important to
note here is that this access
committee has already approved under the
extent permission in the 2017 and this
particular drawing has also been
discharged under that extant permission
with suffolk highways approval to say
that this is an acceptable access so we
have
technically accepted this as an access
twice over already
so i'm just going to move on to if i
just zoom out a little bit should let me
there we go into some of the
proposed speed reduction measures i
think it's really clear to add to
members here that this is not going to
be controlled
at this stage as an approved document
there is a condition that the section
278 will need to come forward as part of
the highway agreements
but this is just indicatively showing
what could come forward
and like i say these conversations are
ongoing with our suffolk highways teams
at the moment
so we potentially will see a drop down
curb and tactile paving
opposite a footpath that runs to the
primary school so anyone that occupies
the site of development will be able to
use the path
all the way around and then cross the
road at the drop down curve area
crossing point we also have edge of
carriageway markings that will be going
in
approximately here in terms of
notifying that we've got a reduction in
speed of the carriageway and this is the
area that we'll be looking to see the
footpath widened and as a result that
will see a reduction in the
road width but no less than 5.5 meters
which still meets highway standards
and suffolk highways are happy with
and again just some more of the suite a
little bit further out in terms of the
improvements
some further road markings to denote the
30 mile an hour speed limits
um and we'll also as you can see here
this is the type of thing that we can
you might envision it again these are to
be agreed with
suffolk highways under the section 278
so i'm just going to go back to where
the access is going to come in this
is where the access will be
this is the house that's to be
demolished these green rings that have
been highlighted here
are tpo trees trees with protection
orders on as well
as well with this one this tree within
the access area is not to be removed
this is taken from the tree report that
was submitted as part of the application
you can see that all trees with a green
solid ring round them are to be retained
all trees with a green dotted line
will be removed so you can notice that
there's a tree here on the entrance that
will be
retained it's just outside of the red
line plan as well with the hedgerow here
but obviously the hedgerow at the front
will come out
and at the back to be removed
next slide is more of a concept plan
there's nothing here that we will be
conditioning against because that's
settled for reserve matters
and the applicants have submitted this
detail in terms of what could come
forward
i don't think there's anything here that
we really need to dwell on because
we can't expect that they would exactly
look like these images
reserve matters but it's just an
indication of what could come forward
and again
an idea of a scout hut at the top here
i think again really important to note
is that the development will not be
building the scout hub but rather
gifting the land in terms of
to the scouts for them to to develop the
hut themselves
this is a conceptual layout and drainage
um plan that was submitted this was a
requirement that was
different to the 2017 approved document
approved permission this flood is
requested by floods apologies
and this basically shows how that the
drainage can fit into the site alongside
the areas for development
there's a couple of key points that i
would like to highlight on here at the
moment we're only showing a 15 meter
buffer on the eastern boundary
as part of some of the ecology
requirements they will need to see a
much larger buffer on this edge
and so we can anticipate that some of
these roads will
look slightly different in terms of
reserve matters
and also note in the design section of
the report i've
given some pointers to say that we're
unlikely to support a design
layout in terms of this because it's
very rigid particularly with a road that
runs straight through the middle of it
so we can expect to reserve matters
we'll see a slightly different scheme
um but i think it's key to note here
that they've satisfied the floods
uh suffolk sorry suffolk floods
authority
in terms of showing how they can
actually fit all the drainage system in
along with development
so i'm just gonna move on to landscaping
now um
the landscape being uh what was provided
visual impact assessment um you can see
here that we've got the redline plan
for the site you can see a network of
public rights ways to the north
to the south and to the south east uh in
essence
all of this area here is not visible um
from the site or to the site should i
say i think the key things i want to
highlight here is footpath 12
and footpath two again this report
shows through photographic evidence that
the rest of the footpaths can't see it
due to the valleys to the north
so if we start with footpath 12
this photo has been provided and again
i'll just do a little zoom in
so you might better see a little bit
more detail
you can just see the tops of the houses
there of barrow hill
this red line does not denote the height
of the
um development again that's something
for reserve matters and we definitely
wouldn't be expecting to see high of
that but that was some concern with
objections that had come in
that perhaps this was denoting the
height of development i can assure
members that this is not the case
uh we're looking merely at where the
approximate extent of the site in terms
of the whip so that the boundary lines
here
it's just noting that so we're very
unlikely to see any landscape impact at
all of the site
from footpath 12 from the north and then
when we look at
six a lot more close up so again these
are the rear of the houses on bacton
uh sorry barrow hill um
and you are likely to see this is where
the allotments is approximately
unlikely to see some roof scapes come
into this space here
it's a very negligible amount of harm
that's taking place
so what i'm going to do now is just have
a look into the site in terms of
footpath 9 because this is really where
the landscape impact is going to happen
is how footpath nine is actually
experienced you remember i've just got a
aerial shot here this is where this uh
shot was taken from
and footpath nine runs along here it's
just a very short video
to get an understanding of the site so
it should start
playing now as we move across we can see
the rear houses along
the high street to the south
area where the access is going to go in
here hopefully my curse is staying
up to date with that we've got gotzfield
close the bungalow's here
and the two-story dwellings here and
then the rear of the dwellings on barrow
hill with the community woodland now
coming to shot
and as it pans around facing north we'll
now begin to see the start of the
allotments and that kind of open space
like i said you might be able to see the
roof escapes through from
path 12 and then for path nine that
carries on
towards the north so that's where we
anticipate that the
severe amount of harm will happen from a
landscaping point of view
it's how footpath 9 will be experienced
both for our
landscape consultant and the report that
was submitted set out a
set of recommendations for mitigation in
terms of buffers
and the way that we would expect the
reserve matters to come forward and
what we didn't do in 2017 that we do
this we condition the report submitted
as part of any reserve matters
that shows how um the design has met
those requirements set out by our
landsat consultant and
their landscape report so i think that's
a really good
addition to this permission should
should we go forward with it
so just in terms of policy context we
had a look at where the settlement
boundary was earlier on in the
presentation
currently that sits outside of the
settlement boundary
we do offer less weighting to this due
to the
inconsistencies with the mppf as set out
in the report
we also highlighted that we've got some
areas of harm to listed buildings which
we have attributed
great weight to as part of the mppf and
our policy
cno6 moving on to cs11
we have a majority of a positive
interaction as set out in the report
with cs11
but it's very important to note that we
do have a conflict in regards to
evidencing local needs
in terms of a housing survey we
definitely have a district need here
as approved in 2017 we also have a
district need for
affordable housing um there's not
necessarily a local need that's been
identified in this instance
but i think it is key to point out that
we do have a majority of
a positive interaction with cs11
so cs15 again positive interaction when
considered against all the criteria that
the outline application can engage with
and this is detailed further in the
report with each criteria point
and in terms of the access again we have
suffolk highways
who have assessed to say that we've got
no impact the
public highway in regards to the
congestion or safety and i think this
has been reaffirmed the fact that we've
agreed this access once under the
outline permission and discharged it
under a condition as well already
so in terms of balance we've got
heritage harm on one side we've also got
a loss of grade three agricultural land
and we've got a site that's technically
outside of the built-up area boundary
we do have some severe harm to the path
nine but this can be mitigated through
condition and
design so any moderate harm is being
attributed to this and more detail will
come forward as part of the reserve
matters in terms of an assessment
of how harmful any proposal is on that
instance
and then in terms of um benefits we've
got additional housing
additional affordable housing still
contributions
we have a low reliance on a motor
vehicle here with access into the
village to some
services and facilities but we've also
got good public transport networks that
this
application will actually contribute an
extra 50 000 pounds towards
the bus service we don't have any impact
to the wider landscape
and of course we have a great weight
given to the extent permission that's
currently in place
i think it's important to say that if
this was refused today we could expect a
reserve matters to come in at any point
later on this afternoon up until the 1st
of may
and housing can still take place on the
on this site as a result of that
we've obviously got no highway safety
issues
i think also a very key point but very
little weight is given to this at this
stage
the emerging joint local plan actually
puts the site
inside the settlement boundary of acton
albeit that it's not an allocated site
in this instance we can just see the top
of damage road that is denoted as being
an allocated site
and this because 2017 permission uh
hasn't been captured as part of the
emerging local plan um obviously we are
due to submit this to the examiner
shortly and once that goes into that
stage we'll see that this will take more
weight in the future
in terms of conditions um i think again
another important note here is that
we've actually spoken to the applicants
and agreed that this
new permission would have an 18-month
deadline to submit reserve matters
against
we'd ordinarily see at least a two-year
one so we've reduced that to improve the
deliverability of the site and again the
majority of other design considerations
such as plot boundary treatments hard
and soft landscaping
have all been conditioned in this
instance to come concurrent with the
reserve matters
this will allow us a cohesive approach
to design
later on this is something that the 2017
permission didn't do
so we might see scale and layout
provided
and then we'd see hard and soft
landscaping treatments come later on by
our condition
through this one we're advising that we
capture it all at once and make sure
that we get a really good proposal come
forward at reserve matters which i think
is a good point
i've got some slides to go through in
terms of photos there's quite a few
i'll skim through them if you keep a
note of the slide number and where the
photo's been taken from
i can always come back to it but i will
skim through them as there's quite a few
so do let us know uh so this is from
within gotzfield
looking over the top of the bungalows
the site's just behind here we may see
some roofscape
come into this space here moving up to
barrow hill and opposite the
acton wildlife community woodland and
you can just see the site in the
background here
this is the last house on this side of
the road
just stepping inside of the woodland
again this is a fence line of that house
and you can see the boundary along here
and the site you'll notice is higher
on the kind of north eastern side and
slopes downwards
towards the village in this side
and some of the footpaths that are
currently used inside the site and the
bungalows in gotzfield
and this is looking northwards
up to the northeast corner again you can
see the topology of the land there is
slightly higher
and then this is standing in the
northeast corner looking down at
gotzfield
to the south and then high street
over to uh sorry godsfield was over to
the west
this is now looking south with apologies
and footpath nine
on the left-hand side of the screen here
for path nine leading out
of the site to the north a bit more
central where you can see the allotments
and this is where the hedgerow will be
removed at the rear of the dwelling
that's to be demolished to allow for the
access in you can just see that dwelling
there that's to be demolished
again a bit closer up and then this is
looking with the access
directly to the left here towards scott
fields
and then north towards barrow hill again
you can see that slope
slight slope gradual slope up into the
northeast corner
this is the footpath nine going out
southwards towards high street
and then this is the entrance to the
footpath looking opposite this is
sunflower
cottage and lilac cottage the grade two
listed building
and then this is looking off to the east
with
welding wardenfield road
around that bend and you'll notice this
is the existing footpath
which is quite nice and wide already all
the way into the village
as we move along we can now see the
grade 2 listed building marigold
which is opposite the site which will
come into here
that's great to build him
and then this is the building to be
demolished and then the
evergreen hedgerow at the front
that will be removed to allow for the
access to come in here
another shot of the building to be
demolished and then just looking back
along high street again
the path and then this is where we can
expect to see
the drop down curbs to come in place to
allow for the access
up here into the primary school
this is paul house the other grade two
listed building
then have the bus service 753 that's in
acton that leads
from at a great welding field and then
into sudbury
the convenience store and the bus stop
in here
and then just looking back again
convenience store with a crossing
to the bus service on the other side of
the street with an island in between
and then just a shot looking back up
into barrow hill so skim through those
quite a lot so if you want to go back
and review any of those please do let me
know
in terms of the recommendation uh the
application is to be granted
subject to the section 106 and the
conditions set out in your pages 38 to
40
and also along with some additional
conditions set up your table papers
thank you very much chair thank you mr
martin that's very
very full and detailed report and
i'll just check remember service any
points of clarification i've got a
couple
um you did point out in the last
pictures i think
that was a detached house that's been
demolished
that's correct yes detached one of the
plans i think it was number eight
sort of show it as though it was um semi
but um it's not it's a detached house
that's fine
tension on the side there which may make
it look like a semi-detached very
close yeah yeah that is yeah it's
detached uh the
second point um the has there been any
request
for a pedestrian crossing or an island
crossing
at the entrance uh near to where the
public footpath is opposite because the
school children
yeah has there been any talk of that
with highways at all
or no there's no requests from highways
at this stage in regards to that um
i haven't been made aware from our
colleagues in suffolk highways for that
um that wasn't something that was gained
as part of the
2017 uh permission either
right so a question can be put to the
applicants on that point then agree
that's fine uh thank you and and
can you just clarify again the point
regarding
the um the outline plan permission that
runs out very soon
but they have up until the first of may
where whatever decisions are taken today
they can come in with reserved matters
on the existence side is that correct
can you just explain that again
yeah no that's correct
i think it's key that to sort of uh to
go into a lot more detail which is set
out into
the report the permission actually
lapsed in early december 2020
um but obviously to do with the covid
act that we currently have in place that
has been extended automatically
uh with no further details required from
the applicants up until the 1st of may
so again we could expect to see a
reserve matters in this afternoon
um we could expect to see that on the
1st of may and again if it was submitted
on the 1st of may as a major application
that could take up to a 16 week process
so we might not actually see an approval
or refuse will take place until sort of
end of summer on that one
but we can expect to see a reserve
matters submitted
any day between now and the first of may
on this site and we would have to
determine it
right and if they were asking for
permission on this for outlying this is
no different to the one that's in
existence at the moment
that's exactly correct it's it's um an
identical um
uh application that they've submitted
the only additional information is some
extra information from floods that was
required as a result of policy change
since they last got the mission
right that's just so we're clear but i
can see some hens have gone up so i'm
going to start
um kenzler jameson
thank you uh thanks for clarification
yeah yep sorry yeah thank you chair and
thank you jamie that was a great
report um just wanted to clarify the
enhanced ecological enhancement
enhancement measures
conditioning that they relate to the
report on the third of march
from play services and
the the five conditions in that report
and the other
one i was going to ask is there's a
condition for
measures to improve sustainability of
development does that relate to the
recommendations coming from
environmental health
on in december yes that would be correct
um i think we would also expect to see a
report as part of the sustainability
uh sustainable measures in regards to
how the
uh future houses will be heated um
car charging points all of those type of
things would come forward as part of
that in reserve matters
exactly ecology yes there was an issue
whereby the applicants had provided
extra information
to satisfy our ecology
consultants unfortunately that stuff was
put on our website as sensitive so no
one could actually see it so when we
actually consulted
our colleagues they still raised a
holding objection but we made sure that
that was then made visible to which they
released that
um in terms of suffolk wildlife trust
they actually provided or upheld their
holding objection
we've had further conversations with
them that set out in the the table to
papers
in essence they're quite satisfied that
an additional survey report can take
place for reptiles
within the actual site itself i think
we're understanding with our ecology
in colleagues and place services that
that probably goes above and beyond the
requirements that are needed by the
applicant at this stage
but the applicants are quite happy to
oblige with that as part of condition so
we're actually finding we're going a bit
above and beyond with the ecology
requirements in this instance
so we expected them to provide a
environmental management plan
ecology management plan biodiversity
enhancement strategy
you know and the lighting design scheme
yeah yeah and i think what's really key
here counselor is these things weren't
captured as part of the 2017
um permission that was approved um we
did have some ecology
conditions that were added to that but
again we in conversations with the
applicant
we're recognizing the change of the mppf
that came in in 2019
and we're being a lot more stricter in
terms of the ecology conditions in this
instance
and they're happy to agree with that
approach okay
thanks thank you canceler
airs
hey now i thought it was brilliant i'm
just wondering
um about i've read through all the
details but it's nothing from suffolk
county council about school
places um so i just wondered
have they cons you know do we know
anything about that at all
because i know with the um the local
high school
they're going to lose six forms which
would mean the other high school would
have
need more places i just wondered if
you've had any dealings with them
am i still here hello oh yes we can hear
you
excellent yep um so yes we i have had
conversations with the contributions
team in suffolk county council
and they have put forward what they
expect the contributions to be this will
be captured as part of the section 106
and the seal requirements as well
um so the application if approved will
have those benefits of financial funding
towards the schools
yeah okay um come back
at the moment well there's points of
clarification
that's right at the moment we don't want
to get into debate yep okay well i'll
bring it up in debate
okay if you want those exact figures i
can try and dig those out before you go
to debate
that'd be helpful cancel that ears
yes it would be very helpful thank you
we'll give you time to find them
i've got councillor mclaren next
oh dear thank you chair
very difficult isn't it this um jamie
thank you for that i found that
um presentation extremely
clear but i'm not very good at um
measurements uh i just want to ask i
know the access has been approved
but can he just explain to me
does that allow two vehicles to be
on the access at the same time
and would the access be impeded
for emergency vehicles or waste
collection vehicles
yeah great question and the access if i
just go into
the drawing here um is going to be at
least 5.5 meters wide
so that will allow two-way traffic to
flow through and there will be no reason
why
any waste vehicles or emergency vehicles
would be impeded in this instance
um we do show as well right it's
actually six meters wide apologies
so we've got two meter wide footpath six
meter wide access which allows two-way
traffic and then a two meter wide
footpath on the other side
with a slight area of landscaping that
will be able to go in either side as
well
okay thank you very much jamie thank you
chad
thank you councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman um yeah whilst
we're talking about about the
access does the does this drawing which
is the one that was discharged
presumably from the previous application
count towards this current application
or do they have to submit a new one
no they have submitted that as part of
this application so we would no longer
be adding a condition asking them to
supply this additional information again
so this would be an approved document
this one
whereas the other slides that i showed
you
in regards to the suite of improvements
are not approved documents because that
will be captured as part of the 276 but
this would be an approved document this
one
that would capture the visibility
displays and the measurements for the
roads and pathways
so so in actual facts
submitting a an approved drawing is
counted as
actually building an access point that's
correct
uh and the second point i was going to
ask was where is the current access to
this piece of land
so if i come on to maybe this slide
maybe this slide would be a good one to
show
in terms of access um in terms
of access there is footpath access into
the site here
and i would suggest that there is and
probably enough access for a vehicle as
well in terms of agricultural
there is no other vehicle access on the
site at all
there are some pedestrian cut-throughs
via the allotments and
committee woodland again like i said
locals kind of follow this round
um i think i had the photo
and just check this one here there's a
kind of gate here and i think over time
obviously since 2017 it hasn't been used
as an agricultural field it's been left
as a grassland
so this footpath's probably become
overgrown but i would suggest that this
is the only access for
agricultural vehicles in and presumably
the
landowner has access to that gate so
that was the original
vehicle access to that piece of land yes
that's great
why is it not being expanded on and
developed for
the new development when you use of it i
think
we would end up if you follow this round
it it's a bit windy
um let me go there's a better
shot for it maybe this one here so as
you come down here
it branches out and this area here
is is very thin uh i i would say that
that'd be very tight for a vehicle you'd
never get two-way traffic along there
um from looking on the site and walking
down there
there's a gated area around here so i
presume that there's an extra access for
what was
agricultural at that stage there i would
suggest in terms of the width of area
that we'd be able to put an access in
here we wouldn't be able to get two-way
traffic in
and that's why it's appropriate to have
a look at demolishing the house and
allow for two-way traffic more centrally
also we've got the bend so the
visibility displays would be hindered
in terms of that bend there to have 100
up to 100 houses coming off via that
access
thank you uh councillor owen
hello um thank you chairman
um thank you for a good
um um just gonna ask
with the community woodlands we call
that
nature reserve i just want to put that
in there anyway because
living in acton um which is up by the
allotments yeah and
it's it's what they've made as a nature
reserve and everything
yeah yeah i just thought just so
everyone knows when
when they talk about the nature reserve
that's what they're talking about
thank you and and another thing why
why haven't they gone with the other
outline if i can if i'm allowed to say
this
why aren't they allowed why haven't they
gone with the other outline
planning is there any reasons yeah my
understanding is
and perhaps the applicant would go into
further detail
but my understanding is is that at the
moment the applicant is a land
uh promoter so uh they were hoping to
seal a sale on the land just prior to
covid
and obviously covert hitting in a year
ago um
brought a lot of uncertainty and it
wasn't necessarily that that deal fell
through but it was sort of put on the
table
and put on hold um as a result they've
come
closer and closer to the end of their um
current permission
and therefore would be prudent in a
business case to make sure that they
just renew this application
uh hence the reason we've only gone for
18 months on the condition
as to provide reserve matters on rather
than the full two years that would
ordinarily ask for
um but that's my understanding in
essence covid was the issue
in this instance of delivering the site
to a developer to then bring forward the
reserve matters and development
can i come back with that are we still
you still doing the same reserved
matters then
as you was in the other outline so as it
stands
and and hopefully this doesn't
complicate matters and so if if this got
refused today they could submit reserve
matters under the extent permission
if this got approved today they could
submit reserve matters under either
of the two permissions so either the
2017 or this one
after may the first they would only be
able to submit reserve matters onto this
site
so we would have to check if reserve
matters was submitted between now and
may the first which one it actually tied
to because
again we've got a lot tighter conditions
that are put forward on this application
than the ones in 2017.
so they could still be submitted reserve
matters under the 2017 application
even if this one was approved or refused
okay thank you but obviously if this one
if we were minded to approve this one we
would get better conditions
on this uh be um more beneficial
um cancel our and i think that could be
a good question to put to
the applicant
i see no other hands up so
i think we'll move on no we're sure
sorry i've got
adriano's council adrian osborne's hand
up on my screen i don't know why it's
not showing it online but it's not
um okay um
i was born uh thank you mr chairman and
um
thank you for finally finding my hand
raised um
no i still can't say it but uh i accept
every time um
anyway thank you very much um can i just
say
excellent presentation jamie and your
comments that uh
i was going to ask to er from counselor
hinton's clarification
uh was was part of that but there's just
one
i can remember the site visit we had all
those years ago
um the um
uh footpath nine is that that part of
the bridal way
that was talked about that there was a
great lot of conversation about
that bridal way is that part of footpath
nine or is that
not the bridal way i would understand
that it's definitely a public right of
way we have had uh some comments that
came in from the british horse society
in terms of what surface they would like
to see on there so
um it could be construed from that point
of view that it is the bride away as
well
um i saw no signs at that stage to
suggest on-site visits and i checked
both ends to suggest that it would be a
brighter way
only a public right-of-way um but i
haven't seen anything that suggests it's
a brighter way also
yeah you show the on that drawing um
if i know mr chairman on that drawing
you show the entrance
to the high street from from there the
other end of that does that
does that have a clear access onto
barrow hill or um
just by the side of the allotments i
believe yeah it's only a footpath access
it's definitely not a vehicle one so
i've got a photo here
so you can see here that we've got the
girders on that northern part
um that show that it's only a pedestrian
footpath it's definitely not wide enough
for a vehicle to get through there
either
thank you very much jamie good
clarifications thank you thank you
thank you right
um see no hands up so
we'll go to the public speakers now
parish councils
christine johnson of acton parish
council you madame have three minutes in
which to address the committee
um which should be timed by the
governance officer
and at the end of that i'll see if
there's any questions for you
when you're ready if you like to turn on
your mic
and turn on your camera we won't start
until we've got your up and running
can you hear me chairman i can hear you
yes
we can't see you but and you could be on
the phone to us i'm not sure
no i'm i'm here and i can see me on my
screen
ah i can see you now yep thank you
chairman
right may i begin
ready now yes please thank you
members first of all a point of
clarification
mentioned has been made of the footpath
nine
as it leaves the high street could that
not be used
as an entrance to the site it cannot
because it is not in the ownership of
the applicants
the applicant's land only is inside
their red boundary orange boundary on
the map i'm looking at now
the other end of that path is owned by a
local farmer
there is a right of way for agricultural
vehicles over it
in order to access the land
in the applicant's ownership and that is
all there is there
the northern end of that path is owned
by the parish council
neither of these landowners have been
approached in any way
having said that i would just like to
continue that
to create an acceptable visibility
display
which the highway authority acknowledges
will have to be below its normal
standards the developer
will widen the footpath along the road
thus reducing the road width to 5.5
meters
less than the width that's being
suggested for the new development
on the main road through the village the
c711 is a regular bus
route the required width for a bus route
is six
meters the road is used by large
vehicles accessing the industrial
straits at either
either end and by agricultural vehicles
in order to pass each other
they will have to drive over the newly
widened path
the parish council believes the decision
taken in 27 was wrong
but understands it was inevitable
because of the constraints imposed upon
you at that time you had no
choice but you do have a choice now
since 2017 the site has been actively
marketed by leith planning whose own
website
says they are experts in their field and
have a proven track record of delivering
projects in time
yet they have failed to find a buyer in
the last three years
a site with outline permission for 100
homes
in a suffolk village should have been
snapped up the originally intending
purchaser withdrew
since then two companies have surveyed
the site and the road in a very detailed
manner
but nothing has come of it why not the
applicants
cannot blame the pandemic other sites in
the area have sold and worked commenced
the parish council considers that in
view of the unproven housing need
the current construction of a hundred
homes at damage road
which happened after you gave permission
for this site before
and the contrived vehicular access to
the site
you have sufficient justification for
not renewing this application
and urges you to refuse your consent as
it would appear the site is
unviable if you are minded to give
consent however then we ask that
conditions
imposed should include the provision of
large green buffers to protect the act
and wildlife site and allotment land
thank you very much mrs johnson your
time is up
thank you thank you mr chairman
thank you uh right i'll serve as any
questions for you
um members
uh yes uh there's her hand cut up i
can't see who it
is i'm afraid
thank you yes thank you very much
and um good morning uh mr johnson um
could you just um explain to us so that
we're we're clear what what what is
acton parish council's position are you
supporting this application or
objecting to it and the reason i ask why
is because reading your representations
it would it would appear
that there's an objection but then
halfway down it says the parish would
like a muger included within the site so
um i'm not clear as to um as to what
your actual position
is with regards to this development
please
the patch council's position is
that it is totally opposed to this we
think it's the wrong
thing in the wrong place um the damage
road development
right people didn't like it but they've
accepted it's going ahead and it's going
to work
but this site won't work and the reason
we suggested the mugger
was because if it does get permission
and it does go ahead
a suggestion for a scout hub with a
canoe
store is not what we need in acton acton
has
very little provision for the older
children
and if you're going to put something for
young people
into this site then we thought that if
something
if a sweetener has which is all it is is
being offered
then a mugger would be more used to us
than a canoe site as we haven't actually
got a river
that's the reason for that but we're not
in favour of the thing in the first
place
thank you i hope that's helpful
councillor parker
um councillor busby
yeah mr johnson good morning uh you you
started to mention some of the
conditions that you would have liked to
have seen if this is approved what were
they
um we are
concerned and it will now appear that
that
thought is being given to green buffers
we want no development to be within five
meters of the public right of way
because that is a very
important thing to the village
the fact that you've had 1200 uh
people signing a petition about that
path
shouldn't make that clear to you there
shouldn't
there also needs to be as the ch i think
the chairman mentioned
the possibility of a road crossing to
get children
over the road towards the school because
there is
there's a little footpath linking to the
school
from the high street but children have
got to cross the road
that high street carries an inordinate
amount of traffic
because it's used as a unofficial bypass
for sudbury always has been and i i
should imagine that practically every
one of the members there today
will have used it for that reason in the
past um
we accept that's what happens but it's
not good for crossing
the we're worried about the uh
heritage properties on the uh southern
side of the high street there's
and may i just say to you officer
that the thatched cottage which is the
one that is listed is not
marigold the house next door is called
may gold and spring cottage is the one
which is listed
just for clarification yeah we're we're
clear that might help it's very easy to
get them two names muddled over the
phone
i just thought we'd keep clear what
we're talking about um
there's no edge to those and we would
like to see
some something put in place
to prevent the vehicles from driving
right up to the edge of there and
damaging their fence the lady living in
spring cottages
um i'm gonna have to stop you there um
mrs johnson because you're getting into
our debates
uh no no hang on a minute let me just
finish um i think those points of the
road
whips um i'll get the officer
to comment on them because this is not
the first time we've heard that that
road is narrower
and two vehicles have difficulty in
passing or large vehicles
so i think we need to get that clarified
um
councillor busby had you got the con
the what your answer that you wanted
because we did
thank you thank you right thank you um
i've got council
uh airs followed by councillor hinton
thank you chair thank you very much mrs
johnson
and i just wondered are um thinking
about the
i know this isn't the damage road i'm on
about school places
do you know if there are any spare
places at acton primary school thank you
there are no but no spare places nor is
there any land on which to extend the
school
unless you put an a story or something
like that there's
they've used up all of their land really
thank you mrs johnson councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman uh morning mrs
johnson uh
just a quick question on public
transport because a lot is always made
of public transport in it
the fact that it'll green up everybody's
agenda
how frequent is the bus service through
to sudbury
because we saw one thing there but
presumably the school children have to
go by bus as well
oh yes all the school children go by bus
um
we have um chambers uh
run a in the middle of the day
it's the moment it's on a special
covered timetable
but it's um it's normally
one an hour in either direction to
bury and colchester going through
sudbury along melford labnum all those
places
um there is also a little
town circular bus but that only runs
three times a day and isn't much use to
anybody because it
you can go to the town on it but you
can't come back again so i i've never
quite understood the point of that
thank you i see no other hands up
so i'll take that then thank you very
much
um mrs johnson i'm going to ask the
officer
uh if he'll just come in and clarify
some of those points particularly the
road one
um that was referred to um
jamie can you help us out here please
jamie
have we lost him mark
i'm trying to unmute myself i'm not sure
yes church
yeah right yeah sorry
it was paused yeah in returns of the
road
i think what's really important to note
here is is that um
the area of footpath to be widened
is located in this area here and at the
moment
it's key to the point that it's no less
than 5.5 meters
the the scheme at the moment is not
necessarily saying it will definitely be
5.5 meters all the way across
what we're saying is is that as part of
the section 278 that will be agreed
that it will go no less than two at 5.5
meters which is
as per the highway standards so we might
find in certain areas where the path
doesn't need to be widened at all
it will remain its current width so
highways are satisfied with that you're
telling us exactly that yes
thank you may i offer some um
comments on some other parts raised yes
in terms of
the green buffers the i noted in the
presentation that there
is some landscape recommendations as
part of the report that the applicant
submitted
and part of the report that came from
our landscape consultant
and you also notice in the table papers
due to ecology
we are expecting to see a 30 meter
buffer on that
footpath 9 area unless
additional surveys can prove otherwise
of that requirement and that is to do
with badges
uh in in short and so the
concept plan for the drainage might help
with this
it currently shows a 15 meter buffer and
like i said we are expecting a 30 meter
buffer along here
where we won't be expecting any
construction to take place at all
other than the actual improvements of
the surface um that that may
not be a rigid line we might see a kind
of
wavy line that comes in place depending
on additional surveys that might be
submitted
and we've conditioned that so um that
the parish council can be
confident in seeing a very large buffer
beyond the five meters that they're
requesting
as mentioned by christine johnson just
then um and if it's okay also uh chair
just to mention in terms of the
contributions
uh for the school that was asked for
earlier yeah
um i i will put it on screen because
this is a public document
is as part of the consultees that came
in so it's just easier to show
and your figures are just there so in
terms of early year expansion we're
expecting 155
000 to be made as a contribution through
sil and we also have secondary school
and sixth form expansions also
thank you thank you very much
yep thank you we'll move on um we now
have an objector roberta carradine
would you like to address the committee
you have up to three minutes
and at the end of it i'll see if there's
any questions for you
if you'd like to turn on your microphone
phone
i can't see one of my cameras gone off
put that back on right
um right good morning can you can you
hear me
i can hear you we cannot yes i can see
you thank you
all right okay um concerns of residents
remain the same as those raised in 2017.
the legal binding restricted covenant on
bewley remains in place and is being
completely ignored
suffolk highway's visibility display
wide dimension of 65 meters is not being
met
ignoring the joint ownership of the
party hedge shown for removal and the
use of a one meter travel distance from
the curb
which is not possible due to road widths
are no more than failed attempts to
increase the y dimensions
the properties on the south side of the
high street already experienced
significant vehicle erosion
yet the proposed pavement widening would
push traffic closer to these which
include listed buildings
hdvs and buses often mount the pavement
when passing one another
and the proximity of traffic to
pedestrians is alarming
the predicted rush hour is woefully
inaccurate
and based on out of date of information
it also emits the traffic implications
of the scout hut
the commissioner states the district has
950 scouts and is proposing this will be
the area's hq
journeys will have a similar effects to
that of a school these could be a daily
occurrence of the succession of meetings
from the various age groups
unless restrictions are put in place the
village continues to experience drainage
and sewage issues
low water pressure periods of low power
and telecoms at full capacity
basically the infrastructure is already
struggling the development of a hundred
homes on the tamid road site has started
with developments in chilton and great
walding field which means there is no
unmet local or district housing need
which would necessitate the acceptance
of this speculative proposal
as the community speedwatch coordinator
i can confirm
vehicle volume and speeds have increased
significantly since 2017
and yet no new traffic survey has been
commissioned
concerns about speeding and overtaking
on the high street have led to the
request for an sdr deployment
from the camera safety team and
additionally hgv usage has increased to
such a level
that the parish council is being urged
to apply for weight restrictions
for this c classification road the area
in question has been used for over 40
years as a local amenity
and over the past 12 months has become
even more important
to residents health and mental wellbeing
whilst offering a home to an
ever-increasing range of wildlife
residents question the validity and
viability of this site with its
contrived access
the additional traffic flow and impact
on the utility infrastructure
will be to the detriment of the whole
community thank you
thank you thank you very much uh members
any points of clarification sorry any
questions
objector
no okay thank you very much
uh we'll move on sorry
she's still there that's wonderful uh
councillor busby sorry about that
yeah given the fact that we're um we've
already got an existing
application approved uh this one
provides us with a bit more
protection if you like wouldn't you
prefer to see this one approved rather
than the other one
if i had to choose between the two yes
anything that makes things better would
be an advantage but i still stand by
the site is not viable they cannot find
a buyer who is going to go to the
expense of putting in
a great length of infrastructure to get
down
to the high street i mean the sewage
costs must be
mind numbing and for a hundred homes
it's not viable for a developer to do
if you said 400 houses they'd have sold
it six times over
but for the number of properties that's
being proposed no
no developer is really going to look at
it seriously
until there are all our all other land
options that are
are are used up i don't believe it can
be
viable for it for a developer to to make
so i wasn't even going to comment i was
praying scanned by
my fellow neighbours i think i think
you've answered that question
vincent was another one well
what i'm understanding is therefore that
you
given a choice between the two if you
had to pick one you would pick this one
but actually you want us to reject this
in the hope that the
previous one runs out of time is that
correct correct
thank you thank you
uh there are no other hands up counselor
buzzfeed i think well done
uh yes oh um
jamie edwards you wanted to comment
yeah if that's okay chair thank you very
much i think it's just important to note
that
we would in terms of viability um
if a developer is willing to spend extra
money and not make a profit at the site
then that's up to their their
prerogative
if there was a argument of viability to
say that it's too expensive and
therefore they want more houses as a
result or less
affordable housing than we would expect
viability assessment to be
submitted as part of that argument to
which no argument on that case is being
made by the applicant in this instance
so
in terms of extra costs if the developer
is is at a loss
then then that's up to them but that's
not something that we can take into
consideration
thank you i say your hands come back
cancer budget but it is questions to
um the objector um
if you want to take up that point that
officer
martin edwards has just made that can be
done in debate cancer busby
oh he's gone right then kill we'll move
on then
um we now move to the ward member
councillor melville uh you
have councillor jameson with a question
uh have we i'm sorry my friend isn't
lighting up some of them come out
i was gonna say miss chair i don't have
that either but we don't have the ward
members yet chair we've got the
applicant
oh sorry i jumped the applicant
i do apologize for that i i have it on
another screen
and for some reason that hadn't came up
i
had gone down too far right there's no
other hands up
um sorry uh cancer movies we'll come
back to you shortly
uh we now move to we don't have a
supporter so now ask the applicant to
speak paul grover you have three minutes
in which to address the committee
good morning you'd like to put your mic
on and your
camera on yes can you hear and see me
everybody i
can't see you at the moment
okay my camera's on um do we need to
take down the slide
for that i believe
yeah i hope we've got it now yeah can
you see me now
okay excellent thank you very much so
good morning chairs
and uh members of the committee thank
you for this opportunity to reiterate
the background and justification of our
clients
outline planning application at barrie
hill acton and firstly the application
before you
is in effect seeking to renew an earlier
outline planning commission
granted for an identical development on
the site that was approved in december
2017
whilst a purchaser was secured for the
site sadly the onset of the covert
pandemic created challenges
in completing the purchase for our
client as a charity
as we move out of the pandemic i can
confirm that negotiations are now at the
final stages with a new purchaser
who is keen to submit their reserve
matters applications as soon as possible
approval of the consent before you will
allow us a little more time within which
to submit the finer details of the
scheme
it should be noted that the officers
have limited the time frame for the
submission of the reserve matters for
the new application
and we confirm we've raised no objection
in this regard i'd remind members that
this is an outline application with
access being applied for at this stage
all other matters in relation to the
proposal in terms of layout scale
appearance
and landscaping will be addressed
through the reserve matters
and the applicant is wholly aware of the
comments received during the life of
this application from the local
community
and note the majority of the concern is
based on the impact of the highway
network and site access
in this regard we'd remind members that
the principle of the development for
this site has already been established
by virtue of the earlier consent and
access arrangements approved under
discharge of condition 17
at the previous outline application we
note that highways authority is
supportive of the application subject to
the imposition of conditions and
informatives
on the grant of any consent as well as
the provision of monies within the
section 106 and the 278
which we've raised no objection to it's
understood that the local community also
have some concerns in relation to the
impact of the development on ecology in
the environment
we confirmed that the application has
been supported with all the necessary
reports to demonstrate the acceptability
of the scheme
and any additional matters raised during
the life of the application
have been addressed to the full satisfac
um satisfication
of the statutory council tease which is
included
and resulted in the extended buffer
alongside the footpath
and please note the mitigation set out
within the supporting reports is
referenced within the draft conditions
and will be opposed on the application
we consider that there's sufficient
information provided
to enable the grant to consent so as set
out within the conclusion of the
officer's report this application is
recommended for approval subject to a
number of conditions
informative section 278 and section 106
we confirm that our client is in
agreement with all the requests being
made in this regard
and the application is more than content
to adhere to the obligation set out in
the officer's report
in short this is an application to
effectively renew an
extent outline planning permission for
the site to allow us some additional
time for the preparation and submission
of reserve matters
the site is sustainably located is
proposed to be included within the
settlement boundary within the emerging
local plan
and will help the authority meet its
housing needs on a site that is
available
deliverable and suitable thank you
thank you you've got that in quite good
i know it's difficult sometimes um
points of clarification
i've just got a couple uh which i just
want to put to you
we've heard comments about the
boat canoe house where there is in the
river that runs through acton
um would you be in a position to have
discussions with them regarding that in
the reserved matters
that's the first point and the second
one which i feel
quite strongly about i had a house in
the state built in great cornard
and they had to cross the road similar
to this
and i do agree with the locals when they
say the traffic do drive along that road
is a bit of a rat race run
um a pedestrian crossing or a crossing
there i would think would be quite
useful
would your view be that this could be
looked at or
is this something outside that you yes
so
so let's address the scouts first of all
yes we're open to a conversation we've
been speaking to the scouts in terms of
their need we've allocated the land for
them
yes you don't have a river immediately
here but in terms of the
these scouts going off and using sites
they've
requested the storage of their canoe
facilities that's come from them
and secondly in terms of the potential
for crossing yes we're certainly open to
that in terms of the
278 conversations i guess the question
comes back to
possibly for jamie to pick up in terms
of that accommodation of of that within
the road
um with but in terms of conversations
that's not been raised as an issue
and by transport or by suffolk but it's
certainly something where
we're happy to have a conversation as we
hopefully move the application forward
thank you right members is there any
hands going up
for questions to the applicant
uh councillor busby
yeah the the increase in the buffer zone
to 30 meters
will he eat quite considerably into the
site and the amount of space that's
available for housing
are you still confident that you can
deliver 100 hazards on the site
yes the answer is yes we can we can
accommodate 100 houses on the site if
you look at the previous planning
consent that we've actually got
there's there's a lot of area within
that site and beyond the the hundred
houses
what the extended buffer on the on the
boundary now enables us to do is to
create a biodiversity
enhancement within our scheme which
actually we believe adds to
to the value of the scheme for residents
and for the existing community something
that wasn't available in the previous
scheme thank you obviously a salesman in
your previous life
uh councillor jameson
thank you chair morning paul
if this is approved today will you
accept the conditions
or will your client be happy to go with
the conditions on this
um application or will they try to get
back
reserve matters in time to use the
previous
outline no we've we've got agreement in
terms of moving the
um if we get permission today moving
this application forward which is why in
conversations with the planning officer
we've looked to reduce the time
that we would normally have for the
implementation of the reserve matters
um we've reduced that to 18 months and
that's because our clients committed to
to moving forward the the scheme as best
they can as i
as i mentioned at the outset and our
client being a charity has to ensure
that they deliver the best
um outcome for the site and that means
working with
the potential developer slightly
different than just taking a normal site
to market this is actually making sure
that they
as a charity they meet the charity act
um response in terms of making the best
available scheme that they can come
forward so there
they have to deliver the best scheme
thank you
councillor parker
uh mr kelly grover good morning thank
you i just um
i would like your your thoughts uh or
your comments please um the previous
speakers both from the parish council
and the previous objectives suggested or
contended that
uh that this site was not viable um but
you contend
uh obviously you do but can you put some
flesh on the bones around
why you consider this is viable please
yes so in terms of the
the mix of the scheme we've been talking
to issue as as mentioned before a number
of potential investors
last time around and before the covid
pandemic we
we had an offer on the table and that
has slowed down
um in terms of coming forward and that
has been revisited over the last
um uh 12 months and now we're in a
position where that scheme can come
forward
we have a developer who's looking to
bring this forward
as a as a scheme in its entirety so
we don't question the deliverability
they they haven't offered up
um in terms of a viability assessment
they believe that they can
deliver the scheme with 100 units on
this site
to their capabilities and meet their
requirements moving forward so
they have confirmed to us that they can
deliver that
and again going back to the charity
commission we need to ensure that our
client as a as a charity has a viable
um delivery partner which is what we
believe we now have
thank you um councillor mclaren
thank you chair good morning mr kelly
grover
um being on the planning committee
we hear lots of views from parish
councils
and developers how
often or how many times have you had
in-depth discussions with the parish
council
and perhaps the residents of acton
so there's been a series of ongoing
conversations if you remember
through the uh 2017 planning application
we have attended some of the parish
council meetings where we we don't speak
of them
we attend and listen to what's being
discussed the issues that have been
raised we've then
taken back to either the council
officers or raised with the
uh local wildlife trust or with uh
natural england so what we've sought to
do is issues that we've heard
been raised we've sought to address so
the issue about the buffer
towards the east of a site that's
working on what we believe was going to
be one of the the key issues which was
about the
the movement and the access so we've
sought to provide a response
what we haven't done is then taking that
response directly back to the parish
council
and we've as we've said it's gone
through the officer's report in terms of
how we've addressed that through the
planning conditions
hopefully that answers your your
question
because often um residents perhaps more
than parish councils
uh often um have some concerns about the
lack of consultation
um it seems to be a common sort of
theme with me yes and also if you
remember in terms of where we are with
the development plan
and the boundary coming forward and the
consultation on sites
as the um the local residents would have
also had that opportunity through the
local plan process
in addition to the 2017 planning
application
and the current plan application as i
said in my statement
the two areas which we believe from our
engagement with the community are around
the access point
and the ecology point access we believe
we have
addressed in the previous condition 17
discharge
but as set out in the offices report we
are still
looking to work through the 278 to
improve that access even more to
hopefully overcome those residents
concerns and then we've also been
looking at producing that sustainability
appraisal and also biodiversity
enhancement they were
the key issues that were coming out of
the community which we think we've
addressed
and then finally the one that was raised
again this morning was around the scouts
and what the scouts needs are
as we said we've allocated a site for
them within there and we'll continue to
work with them in terms of
the timing and accommodation of what
they need as
a community group thank you very much
thank you chair problem
thank you thank you uh council oh and
i'm glad you
i've got a little note here to bring you
in but i can't remember what the
question was no no i think they've
answered that question oh good right
anyway cancel out you've got a question
yeah um if this gets approved today
will you continue talking to the parish
yes it um not to leave them out continue
everything any anything you discuss and
continue with them because i think
that's really important
i i completely agree and i think that's
very important if if we are successful
today we need to continue that
conversation
what's going to be key for this site
coming forward is access and use of it
by the community this isn't a gated
development
there is the the the main footpath that
runs alongside the site which is for the
community and for the parish
we've also got a community asset sitting
in there with the scout hut
so this we want this to be part of the
community
and that means working with the parish
in terms of how we bring it forward
also in terms of the legacy as i've
mentioned given that this
the site is owned by a charity at the
moment we want to ensure that there is a
good relationship
going forward not just for the for the
charity as they exit from the site
but also from the developer when they
come and bring the site forward so
working together with the parish is
going to be very important
okay and obviously you've got the nature
reserve there that
would like to yeah
yes so one of the so one of the
questions that we we've been doing
through this
updated um review we've obviously
undertaken
much more in-depth ecology assessments
than we
that then were under the 2017 approval
and that has identified um some
additional works that we need to do
and they've been conditioned and they
relate to the relocation or
translocation of
of mutes from the site we've also been
talking about
um the the opportunities for enhancement
of the site
for um reptiles and other um areas so
hopefully all those
measures should help enhance the nature
reserve and
link to it so that we're getting a more
biodiversity from this site than we
we currently have thank you
thank you i see no more hands
up so i'll take it that's all the
questions
thank you sir for that we'll move on
um we'll now get to the ward member
thank you mr grover
sorry mr chair uh sorry chair matt may i
just put a couple of points in terms of
some of the discussions
yes i think perhaps we can do that while
he's there just remain with you
thank you yep thank you chair and uh so
i just uh
put it to you um uh mr edwards that
um the one of the members said about the
the 30 meter or the
wider buffer zone i seem to think when
vice chairman and i questioned this at
briefing we were told this wouldn't
necessarily be a rigid straight line
because there may be areas where it
wouldn't need to be as wide as that
because uh there are some parts where
there's a badge around so it could go in
and out
along and perhaps a wavy line might look
better than a solid rigid line can you
just clarify that point as well
yeah yes of course the way that we've
worded the condition
is so we don't just have a rigid
straight line along the eastern boundary
we've worded it in a way that they would
need to otherwise
provide additional surveys to suggest
why they could then come in
say 15 meters in one area but then go
back out and allow for that wavy line
that would be a bit more of an organic
approach as well particularly when
you're trying to use the path nine
in terms of how it's experienced and in
terms of some of the points that have
been raised through the discussions
in terms of the crossing um i would
agree that if this was a brand spanking
new application we were looking at face
value
straight from the beginning it's
something that i would as personally as
an officer be looking to
to secure i think we have to be very
careful that we have already decided
that it is acceptable on site without
the crossing um i would be
i wouldn't want to give anyone any
reason to submit reserve matters under
the 2017
application but of course if if the
applicant is
is willing to offer that as part of the
two section section 278
then of course we we can take that
forward and that would be an extra
additional bonus um in terms of the
scouts
there was a letter that was received as
part of the consultation from the scouts
they have um basically notified us that
they are renting
farmer barns at the moment to store
equipment in
having this land so they can build their
own huts would mitigate the need for
rental costs for storing their equipment
they'd have it all in one place and
reduce their logistics and that means
that those funds that they would then be
saving can then go back into the young
people that are part of that
organization which i think is an
important
point to note i've also had some
clarification in terms of school places
into the the primary school
um our colleagues at suffolk county
council have let us know that the
primary school
forecasts provided by the education
indicates that the school rolls
are falling and by september 22
there is forecasted to be circa 50
surplus places in that primary school in
acton that's come directly from my
education department
suffolk county council and then the
final point that i wanted to just say
uh by no means is this a material
consideration in any of the members
decision making today
um but rest assured in terms of my
approach to planning and uh my organizer
first point of being involved in this
site that if the application was
submitted for reserve matters
i'd be more than happy to accommodate a
meeting with the parish council to run
through what the reserve matters has
been submitted
obviously i don't have any control of
the outside of an application being
submitted
but definitely happy to to accommodate a
conversation to the parish council and
give them
prior to their comments being received
for a formal consultation
a kind of presentation of what's been
submitted and where the the different
conditions are being met
or not met may be that case
thank you for that jamie uh just before
you go um
so just to be clear if we were minded to
approve this application
could we add on an extra condition
regarding the pedestrian crossing
uh or not or is this something that
um can be taken away uh because i think
there's a strength of feel and that
something is needed there
i think if so sorry to interrupt i think
that if the applicant is happy for that
condition and there is an agreement to
add it on then i would be satisfied
i think that if the applicant at this
stage was not satisfied with adding that
condition on
i would not see that it would meet the
requirements
uh for a condition to be added would it
be reasonable considering we didn't do
it on the first 2017
would it be reasonable on the basis we
don't have any additional evidence that
shows that there should be
an access there sorry pedestrian costing
when it wasn't required the first time
around
i think in terms of a new speed survey
being taken in 2020 would probably be
unreasonable considering the lack of
traffic was taking place as a result of
covert that might skew things a little
bit
and so i would say i'm happy to add a
condition on
as long as the applicants are in
agreement with it if they're not in
agreement with it i would feel
not so confident to add it on because it
wouldn't meet the tests of the condition
in this instance
i don't know whether it would be an
order of me to ask the
agent whether that would be possible if
you fail you can't give an answer to
that i will understand but i think i
have to ask that
you can ask me the question um obviously
i don't have authority at this point to
talk about adding a condition on but i
think there is that opportunity when
we've talked about the the access and
the
the the narrowing and where we talked
about the reducing the speed
about when we look at that 278 which
which we've already got under
the transport piece how we could look at
whether there was room to accommodate a
crossing in that point so
and so like a politician's answer i
can't say yes
but i think there's a scope to explore
this further and if if we are minded to
approve today
obviously we can we can talk with jamie
further as a case officer in terms of
the wording of the condition
and it might be with one of those
conditions we can look to to amend the
wording to to make reference to
exploring a um an island or
an improved crossing area it's just the
detail of what that would be at this
stage
thank you thank you i can see my chief
planning officers coming in he's going
to
perhaps force us all straight um
given that the hardware authority didn't
request this um
i'd advise trying to parachute in at
this moment
i mean it may be an informative saying
at the reserve matter stage could this
be looked at just to let it know that
it's something
the community would like but i think any
imposition at this stage
wouldn't appear to be reasonable
i mean i just think just coming in
briefly to endorse strongly endorse what
mark has just said
that's very fair advice yeah now i i do
hear
or what's being said uh but also on the
other hand
i've seen first hand in great corner
where
um it wasn't put in and we had to
campaign together and in the end the
developer did put one in um and it's
it solves a lot of problems it really
does and traffic
does go up and down that road anyway
we'll leave that we'll move on
thank you very much mr grove thank you
for your patience there
i'm going to go to the ward member now
which is um
um you madame have three minutes in
which five minutes in which to address
the committee
over to you and get the out of hot water
thank you oh dear i've got the wrong
thing up
right um today we've been informed that
1211 residents have signed a knee
petition with regard to this application
this equals 64 percent of the voting
population of acton
now councillors you're often charged we
are often charged with not listening to
our voters our residents so i hope on
this occasion you are
the housing needs survey should have
been done independently but it wasn't
clause 3.38 refers to district as well
as local needs
but given there are 1200 signatures i
would respectfully suggest that only
local housing needs
be considered and not district-wide
which means there is no need for three
to four bedroom houses
however there is a huge need for
affordable starter homes
with some retirement homes so that local
people who've lived in the village all
their life can downsize and retire
in their village cs 21 refers to the
provision of infrastructure
suffolk county claim is a continuous
this means uninterrupted cycle route
from the development to the school
really maybe they intend building a
bridge
no better a tunnel than the hedgehogs
can cross the road safely as well
at 4.4 they recognize that the average
speed in a 30 mile per hour zone is 38.
does suffolk county really believe that
the proposals will work in an area where
the average speed is 38
during the day when they want to shrink
the road
the document before you states that
intensification of traffic will not
adversely impact
the existing road network really an
increase of 150 cars
coming in and out of
if the committee is minded to grant
outline planning permission i
respectfully request that the
construction environmental management
plan
be very detailed this is key there's no
back door to be used there's only one
entrance
it will have to stipulate a booking in
system
for all construction deliveries
just as retailers do so that you don't
have
four or five articulated 40-foot long
vehicles
queuing up on the high street
waiting to tip and move on
this scenario is already occurring on
another development in acton
with devastating results
the scout hut storage
is going to lead to even more vehicle
traffic
the acton local nature reserve the
allotments
the footpaths that circumvent the entire
site thus creating a green
open space which this development
will remove the fp9
footpath 9 drops down to the pedestrian
access off the high street
which acts as a natural drainage basin
unlike the one on your slide i suggest
you go and visit it
because that's where the water falls
naturally
the local nature reserve and allotments
area is home to an unbelievably large
number of birds including barn owls
it is also home to great crested use
slow worms and other invertebrates
it's a public amenity used daily by
locals and visitors
who walk around the hedges connecting to
and through the northern parcel of
community woodland trail
the removal of a small number of trees
is concerning because it's a
biodiversity loss therefore
that confirms that this development will
harm
it should not the developer is now
obliged to demonstrate how it will
deliver
a biodiversity net gain not a loss
may i respectfully remind the committee
that they committed
to the climate change emergency plan
as well as the biodiversity action plan
this development will harm the village
of acton it will greatly diminish the
immunity value
and impinge on biodiversity offering in
the area
therefore if this grant is to remain in
place i would ask the committee
to be minded to consider a condition
that the developer install
a safe crossing point a zebra crossing
a pelican crossing that's their choice
which would also have the added benefit
of slowing down traffic
in a much reduced road width
also that the developer retain all the
footpaths that circumvent the site
currently
i strongly urge the committee to be
minded in this regard and to hear
the 1211 voices that signed
thank you thank you very much
um councilman um i'll service any
questions for you
uh just one point picking up on the
pedestrian crossing
uh you did hear the officers say that we
cannot
add a condition at this late 11th hour
uh that wasn't added up on the 2017
approval um so
i suppose all you could do is
um agreed to or
voice the opinion that you'd like the
applicant to seriously
look at that point could i ask your
clarification on that
um most certainly i would ask um
the committee to request of the
applicant
that they give serious consideration to
that
um i would also ask that the committee
seriously consider by visiting the other
development site in the village
the issues surrounding delivery of
material of
of construction materials given the
issues that you have
with the access point um you've got it
yeah yeah i think that's the point we
can take up on the
um the works management plan and i'll
ask our officers to comment on that
in fact the sudbury road one if i can
interject the sudbury road is a less
frequently used piece of road
and there are three or four vehicles
queuing up
waiting to turn into the site um
and they have two access points you've
only got one access point
a 44 tonner 40-foot vehicle
queuing up one after the other in acton
it's a recipe for disaster so
yeah i will get the officers to comment
on that point in a moment for you
i'll see if there's any other speakers
i've got councillor airs
thank you chair thank you liz um yes i'm
also concerned about the volume of
traffic
um well my question is also that
junction off the a134
going into acton
has any consideration we need a
roundabout there don't we
yes true but i think that in terms
of um haulage traffic heavy duty
heavy duty vehicles that junction off
the 134
is perfectly adequate going into actin
i think the issue surrounds the 134
and bull lane on the melford side but i
don't believe that's an issue for this
uh committee on this day okay thank you
thank you councillors there's no other
hands up
so if that's the case then i'll ask the
officer if you'd just like to come
and comment on what he's just heard um
jamie yeah thank you cher um
yes in regards to the construction
management plan um
as always we set up a draft condition
list as part of any application that
goes towards committee
um the applicants have had sites of this
they're all listed obviously within the
report a construction management plan is
included in there and one of the parts
of that construction management plan
condition requires them to provide us
details of delivery times
and expectations of deliveries within
that condition so we're expecting to
have that
as part of a discharge condition before
they start works other elements within
that condition they're required to
provide an evidence photographic
information about the current um
condition of the roads and paths
and and then again once the the
development has been provided so to make
sure that we can sort of
check back and say actually it's in a
really poor state to what it was
previously so we put some fail safes in
there to make sure that we may
getting proper development or good
development in this instance i think the
key one that's been picked up there is
in regards to deliveries and
construction
vehicles queuing up in the road uh that
is
part of the condition that's in there
the applicants have agreed to that
condition
uh we would see that prior to
commencement and the last thing that i
would add
was is definitely an unfortunate event
through
uh disturbance through um development it
is of course only a temporary
process whilst the development is being
built
thank you i see um the chief officer
wants to come in
could i just uh i
asked and you might be able to pick this
up um mr russell
um have we learned any lessons with
management plans as a result of some of
the activities going on
in other developments in acton
i mean i try to choose my words very
carefully because i
hear what um jamie edwards the officer
concerned has
said i've heard what the local member
has said
and um i i think we've got to make sure
that
there that there will be more checks or
more improvements or we've learned
something yeah i'll just ignore it
did think that the the damage road
issues might crop
up chair so i've been speaking to
planning enforcement and also
environmental control
um it's the matter has been dealt with
i'm not saying that everything is
wonderful but um
we did react quite quickly to that and
made it as good as possible
um construction management plans are a
good idea we use
them we do you know we do rooting
conditions etcetera but in the end
unless you have um intervention from the
highway authority
you can't actually dictate the weight
and size of traffic and which way it
goes on the highway network so you do as
much as you can
but a local planning authority can't
make a lorry go this way instead of that
way
so it's not going to be a perfect
solution but we'll make it as good as we
can
thank you thank you hopefully that
satisfies you a little bit against my
face
um i was just could i just have clarity
because everything that i've read up in
preparation for this
referred to a construction environmental
management plan
however jamie um edwards only refers to
a construction management plan
right i'll allow that as clarification
yes of course i'm just uh going through
that i think it's
over 40 conditions that have been
drafted uh just to make sure
and if it's okay uh chair my share this
on screen would it be helpful
yeah yeah if you just give me two
seconds
we're really only interested in that one
point at this moment we don't want to go
any wider
as it stands it's it's put down as
condition 31 the number may change but
this is the
prior to commencement construction
environmental management plan
so they will need to submit these
details if i just zoom in a little bit
easier so it might be easier to read
this is what we're putting forward as a
draft condition
and i have had comments back from the
applicant
none of which uh look to reword or
change this condition so this is how we
see that condition going in
thank you um sorry sorry chair also i
think what what council is saying is
have we got a construction management
plan as well which is just
yeah construction management plan is
just a bit further up i believe which is
this one here
there you go thank you yeah lovely thank
you that's answered both
uh points good uh right is there any
other questions to
the board member no other hands up
so thank you we'll move on uh the second
ward member counselor john nunn
mr president
robert
nun he's not present
right mr chairman can i ask do you still
need me present or can i leave the
meeting
uh you can leave them in or you can you
can join in in silence and watch the
deliberations
i'm afraid i have to leave the meeting
thank you very much everyone
uh i'm assuming councillor nam is not
present
um so we're going to move on we now get
to debate
members it's now up to you who'd like to
start in the debate
um the only handoff is canceling my visa
which is
wrong cancer busby
corner i'll start with a quick a quick
one it mentions in the report
that there's actually overhead
electricity lines that run through the
site
now i don't remember those from the site
visit it was quite a while ago and i
can't remember seeing them in the
picture is that correct
good point um jamie
can you help yes indeed so from 2017
there wasn't any my understanding is
that they
are now there and counts uh chair if
it's it's
okay i don't mind showing my slides
again i probably should have
pointed that uh well if you can find one
with it in just so that kenzo busby and
and the rest of us are clear
30 seconds and if we have a look
at these two slides here so this is with
our back to the access
we can see the overhead lines coming in
to play there and that road in the
background is that barrow hill
that's barrow hill yep so you can see
the top of the house is there that's
this area here with the community
woodland
in this area here or nature reserve
hopefully
yeah are we not supposed to build
beneath overhead lines or
within a certain distance of them as it
stands we don't have the reserve matters
in we don't know exactly where the
houses are going to be going
um so that could be part of the reserve
matters in terms of
overhead lines don't go
over buildings i don't think that
there's necessarily
a planning nor reason to say that we
can't build
underneath but there are obviously
informatives from the utilities
companies and what they would prefer
but again we don't know what the layout
is at this stage they would
need to take that into consideration as
part of it we may find that they want to
put them underground as part of the
development
but that will come forward at a later
stage thank you councillor hinton
good everything's clicked in i hope yeah
um
this is a difficult one we're caught
between a rock and a hard place aren't
we because there was a
reserved matters sorry an outline
permission granted in 2017
if it hadn't been for the dreaded covey
it would have expired and we wouldn't be
having this fuss now in terms of which
one do we do and whether we're being
pressured into anything
um i'm a bit disappointed that we
haven't got anybody from highways
present because
once again they are showing their
inconsistencies when it comes to
highways matters because they're quite
prepared to see a road narrowed
by having a larger footpath they're also
talking about
gates on the entrance to the village to
slow down the traffic which is the speed
survey as shown is exceeding the speed
limit by
a considerable amount um and yet
in my own village they were quite
prepared to say well if you open up the
village and create a nice big wide open
space that will slow down the traffic
so they're never consistent when it
comes to these things
uh and you sometimes wonder whether
they've actually turned out to have a
look at them as we found for that uh
application in cable where we found out
that the officer hadn't even actually
been
out to see where the entrance was going
to be uh except that he
had been in in the area about uh two
years previously to look at a tree
um so i'm a bit disappointed in in that
aspect
i think highways is going to be an
important issue here
i'm not a great fan of pedestrian
crossings there was a proposal for
pedestrian crossing in my village which
we managed to stop in actual fact
for the simple reason that we produced
evidence which showed that children get
more children get hurt at pedestrian
crossings than they do where there isn't
one
and that's partly because they often
take shortcuts rather than go all the
way up the road to the pedestrian
crossing they cut beforehand thinking
that the traffic is going to stop for
them anyway um
and that's been proven so uh it's a it's
a
it's a difficult one um i think the
housing needs
is a is an important aspect they haven't
actually shown that there's a need in
that particular area and i think the
district-wide
need is dependent upon homes being built
rather than provisions being granted
because we're still
at running at about 6000 permissions
granted which haven't even started yet
so if they all start we'll have so many
houses here we won't know whether we're
coming or going
um so it's a difficult one i'll see what
other people have got to say on this but
i think it's a very this is a very
difficult one
thank you councillor hinton cancer
parker
yeah thank you chairman um and and yes i
i agree with much of
what councilor hinson has just said
there we are in in a very tricky
position
um so i i'd i'd like to get some uh
understanding from uh you know from
perhaps a legal position or a technical
position with regards to
um i mean obviously as a planning
committee it's within our gift to decide
how we how we decide this application
today but given that we have an extent
um uh um what are for example the
ramifications
if members were minded to uh to refuse
this application can we even do that
given that the circumstances
um and all the features of the
application are precisely the same as
they were back in 2017
so that's my question but if i may be
permitted um
chairman i i just want to to make a
statement and that is
that yet again here in acton uh
we're being faced with a substantial
application that's before us
um and i'll just take on board the
comments that counselor mal vasey said
you know that we ought to listen
uh to out to uh to the members of our
public
um and as we've said before and we said
it at the damage road application
last year as well we are so often
informed in this committee now um
with the existence or the emergence of
neighbourhood plans
and yet here again we're looking at a
large application in acton
but no sign of the neighborhood plan and
i just i just
i i i'm somewhat puzzled uh as to why
a village such as acton which is so
attractive to work to developers and i
know it's not material
to this application but it does tie our
hands as a planning uh committee and
i just ask we've got a lot of experience
in acton uh a
councillor maybe herself is chairman of
the parish council
we've heard from uh from from one of the
ward members labour member
why have we not even proposed a
neighbourhood plan in acton so
anyway that's that's not material to
this application but um but i'd
i'd be interested in getting an answer
the first question thank you chad
you've made that statement and i'm sure
that will uh land on
people's um ears and in their minds uh
thank you
um legal can you help us on the first
part
certainly yes i mean my planner
colleagues might want to speak as well
but on the first point there's
i think there's two legal principles
it's very it's easy to get mixed up and
they should be distinguished one is
consistency of decision making the
judges have said in the high court and
above that
consistency in public sector decision
making is important principle and if
you're disagreeing with an earlier one
you should um
uh say give adequate reasons but i mean
having said that
jamie martinez your officer mr martin
edwards has not
put a great deal of weight has not
really gone into that in the report
because it only applies with full force
if there is a
the planning balance is very much the
same as and i don't think he's saying
that what he is saying quite rightly in
the report is that there's a different
principle that
there is often quite sometimes when you
come to make a planning decision there
is what we call the fallback position
i.e what the applicant could do if we
said
no today or indeed if we delayed for
some reason
in making the decision and i think it
the fallback position
is where it applies and it is a material
consideration and i think your officer
is advising you quite rightly this is in
this case it's a
forceful and strong material
considerations which you should give
considerable weight on the basis that if
um yes as councilor hinton's just said
because of the
the national emergency the um deadline
for
applying for reserve matters has been
extended
and therefore an application for reserve
matters could be made up until the first
of may and would then extend the light
would
keep the old planning permission that
the december 2017
permission alive um so yes
there it is i mean i hope that's i mean
i hope i've represented jamie's view
fairly on that
did you want to add anything um jamie
yeah no i would agree with that
i think um the only thing that i would
say is if this was a brand spanking new
application without an extent permission
i would expect a little bit more detail
outline in terms of a indicative layout
plan
we've kind of got that through the
drainage concept plan
uh to a certain degree albeit it doesn't
satisfy some of the buffers that their
ecology reports require
um so i think if this was a brand
spanking new application with no extent
permission
i would definitely be asking a lot more
information in terms of indicative plans
for layout to show us and prove to us
that we can fit up to 100 houses on
there
but that's key point is up to so if if
they can't get 100
we might see a an application reserve
matters for 90 to make sure that they've
got all the buffers in for example
i think the other key point is is that
if there was no extent permission on
this
site and we refused today our joint
local plan emerging
uh encapsulates this within the
settlement boundary
um and we are in that joint local plan
favorable with the principle of
development of housing inside the
settlement boundary
and that's a key point here we are
merely looking at the um
principle of development in this
instance with access included
everything else is to come at a later
date and our emerging joint local plan
was it does have very
very limited weight at this stage until
it is submitted to an examiner
includes this site within the settlement
boundary of acton
thank you well members
quite a lot of information there um
counselor buzzfeed
yeah just to take being odds with that
last point uh
it's not an allocated site in the jlp
and i guess it was the the team
decided to extend the village boundary
because
there was a possible development going
to be on that site
but if it's not allocated in the jlp
then
i would have thought that carries as
much weight as the village boundary
being extended
the difference is i mean i was looking
for trying to find reasons why
you would want to turn this down and
the conditions are different the reason
that it got through on the first place
is because we didn't have a
plan yeah we didn't have enough houses
that's right so that was the only reason
it got through
i have a number of concerns really which
i would like addressed
i'm very concerned about the drainage
with that street coming down
straight down through the access
water will pour down there straight
towards the
listed building that can't be allowed to
happen
there's got to be something that breaks
a flow of water on the street if you get
a heavy rainstorm
there could be quite a lot of water flow
down there it's quite a steep
uh hill so the water would come down
i'm also concerned about the access the
i think
the uh construction traffic is going to
have a
difficulty getting into and out of that
access
with the width of the road and that
again puts
the listed building in potential danger
and we're supposed to be protecting
these kind of things
it's only got to take one accident
or one uh driver that miscalculates
and there could be serious damage to the
listed building i don't know how you can
protect against that
um electricity lines i don't like
building beneath electricity lines or in
the process
in the proximity of them either
i think it would be useful if we could
stipulate that there should be
and you'll like this one chair bungalows
on the
southern edge of the site so that
we haven't got buildings overlooking the
gardens of
the the existing houses on the high
street because it is quite a slope to
that site
and if they're perched up high they'll
still peer over
any kind of hedging that we put in there
to protect them
but i don't know i think we probably
want to have 11 ab stains on this one i
think
thank you councillor busby there's
another hands up any other comments from
members
no
counselor barrett
thank you chair um well it is a
difficult one
um but i i don't think abstaining might
might not be
quite the answer um i'm going to propose
that we approve
because i i think we are we are at that
position where
if we don't uh approve this um the
the there is um the alternative is that
the
outstanding permission is just is just
available to the applicant
and the parish have uh agreed
that the proposal uh that we're
we're dealing with today is does deliver
some some better conditions than
than they could see uh under the
previous one
um on on the on
you know there's some there are some
positives there are 25 bungalows
that um we often uh like um to see in
any development that's quite high
proportion
um it does often me mean that we we're
looking at a
age demographic uh attracting older
people who do want to
to um stay in the village um
so i i'll i'll leave it there i'll see
if i can
get a second um so that we can go
forward
thank you uh well i've heard a proposal
from councillor barrett do i have a
secondary
all right uh then from the chair
i will second uh this proposal
because we do need to try and move
forward on this
um i would just like to ask um
the proposal whether she would um agree
to having a
note put on any approval that um
they considered looking at um
a road crossing or making it safer
at that point with either pedestrian
crossing or ireland in the road
or whatever steps they feel that are
reasonably
uh that would achieve the same safety
aspect
i know highways haven't commented but um
we do know it is a busy road yeah would
you be happy
an island would would be uh would be
quite quite useful i think
um a really good signal to vehicles to
sort of slow down and take more care
and i think that that might well be be
good but as as officers have said
we do need agreement from the the
applicant so
well uh if if it's minded to be approved
we could say that we're very concerned
about that issue and add that note on
you'd be happy with that and i'll check
that the
officers that that could be added on
could it
um uh mr russell
i've sent some wording to robert
carmichael
um which rob do you want to read it out
lovely i don't know if it's strong
enough let's see what you think
thank you thank you chair um so what
i've done is i've
updated the recommendation so that it
has the additional conditions
from mr edwards in in the
from the table papers and the following
informative notice follows
that the applicant is requested to
communicate with the local highway
authority in order to provide a
pedestrian crossing
yep um well i'd be happy with that i
don't know whether the proposal is uh
councillor barrett
can you just repeat it robert please
yes of course so
sorry i have to scroll all the way back
right so that's no problem
so the applicant is requested to
communicate with the local highway
authority
in order to provide a pedestrian
crossing
yeah yeah yeah that's that sounds fine
yeah
thank you right members any comments on
on the proposal
no hands up right well if that's the
case
uh it's uh quite straightforward
uh it's been proposed by councillor
barrett seconded by myself
uh they will accept the officer's
recommendation with the additional
um words and that was just read out
regarding the pedestrian crossing
although oh no we've got to go to uh
electronic vote haven't we
nearly did it robert would you like to
take over at this point
thank you chair so if members could
please go to the modern.gov app
and go to today's agenda and click the
plus sign in the top right hand corner
if you could then please go click on the
subsection that comes up
for voting slash attendance and if you
scroll down the
vote is now in progress shown in the
light blue line
yep
right on that
i've voted but it hasn't uh moved on to
the next stage of the photon
okay chair do you want me to take it
wait a minute no that's that's come up
now
as i speak to you uh it's like coming up
right i've just confirmed it okay i'll
just wait for it to come through chair
right thank you chair that's all votes
have come through so the vote
was seven votes for two against
and two abstentions so the motion is
carried
right thank you very much for that
uh thank you members um right i think
uh we're going to take a
little comfort break now um correct
uh yes what is the time uh
11 45 if we get back at five to
12 that gives us 10 minutes is that okay
with members
yes that's great that's great thank you
thank you welcome back members
members of the public we'll continue on
with today's plan and meeting
and we are now
um going to go forward with the builders
and planning application
and the case officer is jamie weimann um
if you'd like to take us forward on that
jamie
jasmine thank you thank you chair and
good morning members
um i'll just share my screen just double
check
you can see everything as well oh not
that
hang on
right can you all see my screen and my
mouse as well
it's on page 43 of your paperwork
thank you yep we can see all that
brilliant okay so i'll be presenting a
full planning application today
at seven hill house newbie road building
which is an application made by the
council for the retention of works to
convert
a former common room which was
previously used in conjunction with
former sheltered housing
to a bungalow with proposed parking
upgrades
members are reminded that this
presentation should be viewed in
conjunction with the committee report
and not in isolation
this is the site location plan um which
goes around the whole of the hill house
building
which is in residential use and the
communal garden areas just around it as
well
the proposed dwelling is shown on this
right hand side
and is contained to a small single story
central section
of this main um hill house building
the remainder of the hill house building
was formerly sheltered housing
has since been converted to 12 flats
which is comprised of six flats on the
ground floor
six flats on the first floor
here we have an aerial map with the site
shown by
the hatched area just here
then we've got another aerial um photo
overview so the site is shown by the red
square
and is accessed south of newbury road
just along here
and as you can see it's set within the
sort of wider
residential area and within builders dim
uh the red lion
public house and the high street are
located to the east and you've got
builders in primary
school located to the south here
so looking west towards the site and on
the left-hand side of this image you can
see the sunlight just here behind these
sort of mature trees
and as you can see it's this single
story portion of the building
so in terms of constraints um the site
is within the built up area boundary
which is shown by
the brown uh line running along here and
sort of will
carry around uh buildings and is also
within the builders and conservation
area which is shown by this purple
and sort of lines and the hatched area
again which is where the site is
and again i'd reiterate that this shows
the entire um of hill house and the
communal
areas but the actual site itself is this
central um single-story portion
um part of the established communal
garden area to the western side of the
site
is within flood zones two and three
which you can see just this little
corner
um however the whole building itself
parking and specifically the common room
um to be converted are all within flood
zone one
the nearest list of buildings located
along the high street
and um a cluster of protected trees are
also located
to the um east here all of which again
are outside of the site
so in terms of providing some background
on um
why this is a retention of uh well
partially retention of application
this is the emergency legislation put
into the cover 19 pandemic
um to assist with emergency situations
which included homelessness
part 12a of this led of this legislation
um gave permitted development rights to
local authorities and health
service bodies as part of these
permitted development rights and covert
19 emergency the council sought to find
redundant and easily convertible
buildings
to help house vulnerable people within
the district
um however as shown by condition b of
the legislation it originally stated
that after the 31st of december 2020
um all land that had been converted for
the purposes of housing vulnerable
people had to be restored
um to how it was sort of previously
um all planning permission would be
required to retain the works carried out
which is
what this application is effectively for
um this deadline for removing works or
applying to retain them has been moved
to this year i believe
i'm sure ian could clarify that later
for us um
however the council had already submit
in an application to retain the works
carried out
um and the change of use in order for
the building to continue to function as
a dwelling
so i've got some site photos here and
these are showing the
elevations and the works that have been
done so as you can see the site is in
the central portion
shown in the photo here and here there's
landscaping to the frontage with mature
trees and a footpath again
fronting the site which sort of runs all
the way um along the residential areas
here is the original floor plan for the
common room
which had a communal area laundry area
store office toilet and kitchen already
installed
so we've then got the um common room was
then converted into one
one bedroom dwelling under the emergency
permitted development rights
and this provides the floor plan which
is in court in accordance
with nationally described space
standards uh so the dwelling
has a bedroom kitchen dining room store
wet room
cupboard and living room um there is
also a store slash heating cupboard
uh sort of separate from the dwelling
just the back which is accessed from the
rear
which is to be used and will be
accessible for maintenance purposes
associated with the wider hill house
building and is not
sort of in use in conjunction with this
um dwelling
we've then got the common room elevation
so this is the original common room
elevations
shown here as you can see it's it's got
a very modest and simplistic appearance
moving on we've then got the proposed
elevations for the dwelling which
has been converted and the red circles
are just to show you basically the only
external differences that have occurred
in converting the um the common room to
a dwelling
um which involved the partial blocking
up of uh patio doors
to just a window and a paneled area and
then
just changing the front door
so just to show you the parking uh
provision to the front so there are
designated parking bays just
along here um to the front of the site a
long new
road and the footpath again just to
point out is sort of opposite the site
and is running
around these parking bays and sort of
along the residential areas
so the existing uh parking provision and
the layout comprises of four bays to the
front of the site
including two disabled bays here
and the proposed parking upgrades to the
existing bays
have not yet been carried out unlike the
works to the existing building but as
part of retaining these works they are
to be upgraded
um which includes basically creating a
new bay and relocating the existing
footpath
just to the west over here
the recommendation is therefore to
approve this full planning application
for the reasons set out in the committee
report
thank you for listening thank you
members have you any questions for the
case officer
no hands have gone up it seemed
reasonably straightforward
thank you
counselor oh goodness right i can't
refer it again
uh so uh i'm trying to find you um
right uh councillor hinton if you'd like
to put your question
just just a couple of quick points uh
for the officer concerned it
uh the report states that there is no
planning history for this
when was it converted from sheltered
accommodation to six flats
that's the first that is not something i
am entirely sure of and i know the
existing building
um was built i think in the 1960s
and sometimes i'm sort of recently i
think when they've reviewed
um council on land and you know
obviously reviewing all of the housing
needs that we have
um that's that's sort of when that
happened um but
it's not strictly relevant to this
application because this application is
solely relating to that single central
portion
well i appreciate that but um if it's a
conversion of
use to six independent properties then
um
that's a that's something that should
have been in planning history but as far
as i agree with you it is
it's not relevant for this but it's
something that we've slipped up on
somewhere or
enforcement or somebody has in not
keeping an eye on ourselves
may i may i comment sure oh no
can i finish first yes let that cancel a
hint and finish and then i'll bring you
both
um and the the other thing is of course
that uh
if it is now six independent dwellings
or seven if we include the bit at the
front then doesn't it not meet the
does it fail to meet the council's part
the county council's parking standards
right um legal did you want to go first
i think mark mark
may be about to say what i needed to say
so i'll let mark go first
thank you mark you're muted
famous words i know uh i was going to
suggest that perhaps um
the change took place um in a different
iteration of use classes order
it may be it took place two five ten
years i don't know when it took place
it may not have needed planning
permission that that was the point i was
going to make
um yes and if i made the safe the same
points
sorry i might i'm not visible am i um
yes there's the same point that
i mean a dwelling house is a dwelling
house is c3
unless well unless it's it's a less that
the element of care is such that it's
only different
different use class but if um a
management decision to change
from um flats for older people with some
communal facility
to um what what the housing officers
called general needs housing
that would not ordinarily need planning
permission in recent years unless there
was a planning condition or a section
106 obligation
required to the effect that it was for
people of a certain age or a certain
need
um and if i think just because jasmine
um as it were kicked the ball to me and
i'd better run with it on
on the temporary rights um the position
as i understand it is the
the original um temporary
provision is until this was until
december 2020 it's been extended to 2021
with a further 12 months to remove
operational development
if it isn't given the permanent
commission that's being applied for here
thank you yes i think that's very clear
now mr chairman if
i've got one other
other small point um where it uh
i was a little bit surprised when it
took look that the applicant is
mid-suffolk district council do they own
this building then or is it part of the
baby housing stuff we picked that point
up in briefing
um sorry yeah this did come up
um i think i think the applicant has
been written down as mid-suffolk
district council but i think he is
effectively baber mid-south at district
council rather than sort of identifying
between the two
no you've confused me there is it babe
or is it mid-suffolk
because it must be one or two because
we're separate entities when it comes to
these sorts of things
i think of a very chair the point is
that it's it's owned by one or other or
both of the local authorities and that's
why it's come to committee
um it's not a planning consideration
that's just why it's at committee
all right
it does rather lend towards the accuracy
of the report so if we can have these
sort of anomalies
i will do some research uh members
whilst you're discussing it i'll do some
research for you oh ian's come along as
well
well i'm just gonna say yes i think i
think it'd be helpful if we looked at
i'm sure the officer can look at the
planning application i mean it's
obviously
bilderson is in baby district so we're
in the right committee but the issue i
don't know that you do sometimes get odd
cross-boundary things in local
government where one council owns
something
just across the boundary i've heard i've
come across that occasion in my career
i don't know if this is such a case or
if it is um
that if like before the shared
arrangements this week would have been a
baber
set of council homes as it were count
council and
older people's provision so um but i'm
sure you can be given some advice on
that
bill justin is definitely in saturday
we're in baber sorry
right there's no other hands up
so members
uh we'll move
um jasmine yes sorry yes
um so the parking provision that is
being proposed under this
is for one additional parking bay which
is in accordance
with parking guidance because it is for
a one bedroom dwelling
um we're not really looking at the wider
um parking provision along the area it
is a residential area and highways have
reviewed
um both the existing parking sort of
provision
um for the main building um as well as
what is needed by this dwelling they are
satisfied that it does meet that
criteria
so there's one additional parking bay
that's fine
thank you no other questions of
clarification
no right we don't have a representative
from the parish or an objector
or a supporter or the applicant agent
i'll now see if the ward member is
president whether he was just to speak
councillor robert
lindsay are you with us
just checking the attendance chair i
don't believe council lindsay is with us
this morning
no i'll just call him once more
councillor robert lindsay you have five
minutes in which to address the
committee of your present
which she isn't so we'll move on we're
now going to debate members so
we who would like to start kenza parker
yeah thank you chair um i i just this is
absolutely straightforward isn't it
i don't want to get involved in in any
you know conference about who owns it or
what have you the uh the proposal
is to um uh provide
accommodation to support vulnerable
persons by providing additional shelter
and that is good enough for me mr
chairman so
um if we're if we're in debate and
there's nothing else to talk about i'd
like to propose that we go with the
officer's recommendation straight away
chair thank you
thank you uh do i have a seconder for
that
well uh oh that's two or three you know
councillor i was born
you were first yeah thank you uh
thank you mr chairman yeah i've i have
uh great uh privilege of of setting in
uh
councillor parker's uh proposal thank
you
thank you um right is there any other
debate wanted in this
no no no no hands up i only cancel i was
born
i think it's an old hand so we'll move
then i'll ask
um robert carmichael olivier takes
directors to the voting procedure
thank you chair so if members could
please go to the modern.gov
app and go to today's agenda and the
plus sign in the
in the top right hand corner apologies
chair and then go to the subsection on
voting and attendance
the vote is now in progress and will be
shown
in the light blue line
all right sort of scroll down just bear
with me
all right i've got that hit that button
now hit that square
confirm confirm
right i've voted i don't know if
everybody else has
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that is 11 votes for
and is unanimous for the proposal good
that's how we like it thank you very
much
uh right then members i think we've got
to the end of um
the agenda for today i'd like to thank
you for your
attendance and uh that and um
we have our next meeting on the
wednesday the 7th of april at 9
30. okay